heads up guys my name is Asher know and
this is just going to be a little video
discussing a potential future series
idea so I was I was just looking through
my github repositories one day and it by
the way if you don't follow me on github
the chair now is my name and you can
follow me but anyway the point is I was
just looking through all these
repositories that i have here just
seeing what I would have done with my
life and and I and I saw these old ones
right and for some reason i forgot what
beneath was and obviously was again that
i made a lot of them dare 29 and i
looked through this stuff and this was
like a while ago this was like april
2014 this was yeah just just over two
years ago i was looking through like
some of the graphic stuff and i was like
i remember this game this is the game
where I try to do that really fancy
lighting and OpenGL and like it kind of
worked but it was really slow and i read
this description and I just thought to
myself like what was the thing here oh
yeah that's right the game might not run
too well for some of you this is due to
the tile red ring not the lighting each
haldren separately instead of being
pushed into vertex rena decimal
taneously that's the problem and i may
fix it later and I was like you know
what I should fix this like it's been
two years like I back then I knew barely
anything about 3d rendering or 2d
rendering heaven in this case and I was
I had no real world experience I was
just kind of I was still in the
University and I was just that I was
only my second year of university and
not that University told me anything
anyway but the idea is that I was I was
a pretty big new back then and I could
like I was looking through this and I'm
like I could totally make this awesome
and I was like hang on a minute I've
made a lot of lot of dare games which
kind of sucked like in terms of like the
code and and like technically like the
ideas weren't even that bad it's just
that there were a lot of things that I
wanted to do and I just didn't have the
time to do them during a lot him dare
right and I just didn't like especially
like with the graphics and there were so
many bugs in them and I was like you
know what would be really cool if I did
this series and me
series in which I kind of went through
all of my old lot of their games and
basically fixed then I not just fix them
but kind of just go through the code
point out all of the things that are
wrong with the code and then fix them
right and I was thinking about this and
I was like that would be like apart from
being kind of cool because it would let
me reflect on my because literally like
lot him dare is a pretty good indication
of my journey as a game developer right
because I started like 2012 this was
this was in 2012 my first love in their
game and that was like I think I had
less than a year of programming
experience when I met Genesis and then
all the way up to like growth which was
recently which was like I did when even
was that like Wonder 34 I guess right so
like December yeah December that was
like I think I made this in like eight
hours or something I was very a very
short but um it's a pretty good
indication of kind of like not not not
like my journey in terms of like my
skills improving that much although of
course they did but it was more or less
just a journey of like hey I remember
making these games at points in my life
and it's just I thought it would be
really cool to kind of reflect and of
course offer for those of you who have
been following the channel four years
you would have remembered all these and
I added I just thought it was it would
be pretty a pretty cool idea to kind of
reflect over them as well as actually
point out like hey I can't believe I did
this and also it will give me a chance
and you guys a chance to see kind of
what i think of the code that I wrote
when I was just starting out and I think
that's really cool as well because I
mean I I actually did like you might
have noticed that not all the games are
on github I recently found the source
code to Genesis which I didn't think I
would it was just in a zip file no
version control nothing I didn't know
how to use get back then and it's like
yeah I just I'm really excited just to
jump in and take a look at what on earth
i created because i remember that game
like I remember the horrors that I would
have done there so be kind of cool to go
through that fix that and also it would
be like a code analysis right and I
would be like this is what you don't
want to do so it would be kind of cool
to go through that and especially with
some of the games like beneath I really
want to take a look at what I do
like OpenGL wires probably port this to
modern OpenGL because i'm sure it like
this was I think beneath was kind of
almost 5050 like there was some OpenGL
display lists' going on and there were
also like vertex buffers right so it was
kind of a mix but going through that
fixing it making it fast because I
remember this had trouble like I had
trouble getting this game to run at
60fps but now i'm confident i could get
that to run past a thousand easily so
yeah anyway going through these probably
not evacuate because that's written
JavaScript maybe not even shift and
growth I don't really care about these
two games these three games too much
because they're actually not bad but an
evacuee is written in JavaScript so
whatever but these these kind of five
games maybe not squared maybe Genesis
time shadow and beneath going through
them at least and fixing them and
talking about them and kind of pointing
out programming practices and how I've
evolved I guess would be really cool so
if you guys are kind of interested in
that idea and you can see most of them
are on github so i'll be pulling them
from there with the exception of Genesis
which I will which I do have someone on
a hard drive because I did find that
recently going through them you know
they're all written in Java as well so
just going through them and and talking
about them I think would be a really
cool idea if you guys also think it
would be a cool idea then leave a
comment below and make sure you hit the
like button on the video i'll probably
just look at the likes and see how many
of this gets but yet i'll leave a
comment as well discussing you know just
if you have any other thoughts or if
you're really excited for this or if you
think it's kind of lame then just leave
your thoughts below and yeah i think
it'd be really cool and and yeah man
it's pretty good yeah see like this
stuff i was looking through there so I'm
like basically adding engine done and
like all this stuff and I'm sure that a
lord a lot of this code like because
that kind of looks nice right but I'm
sure that a lot of this code is is
terrible and in fact a lot of you guys I
remember we're bugging me a bit back in
the day to go over how i did this tile
lighting and stuff so i don't know it
could be cool so with that in mind
because I probably I imagine you guys
would enjoy this series so and by the
way this is one of those series that
doesn't really
require me to spend time like preparing
it like game programming in all those
other series they're kind of like you
know I have to set aside time to plan it
and they'll say it takes more time to
make the videos but these I could just
go through like and do them live right
they don't require preparation it's
going to boot up eclipse and just start
doing stuff live right so it doesn't
require any kind of production really
which is why it'd be a nice kind of
series that I can put up what I don't
have time to tell anything else but the
idea is yeah you know just if you since
we'll be starting with Genesis if you
guys have any questions relating to that
game you probably can't even play it
anywhere because I don't think that I
have I don't even know but yeah I really
should put that up somewhere shouldn't I
I'm gonna try and get like a executable
of this up somewhere but if not I'm sure
some of you would remember it yeah I
really do I really shoot because I think
that if I go to this like this stuff is
all I bet whoops plus a windows that's
not surely that's not there yeah that's
not there this is very old source that's
going to be here this is very old so i
might when i was doing your 12 back
there and that was fantastic anyway i
might try and put this up somewhere but
if you guys have any questions relating
to this game specifically like I guess
just technical questions or any other
questions I just leave a comment below
and i'll be sure to cover them when i do
the genesis so yeah i don't know how
many episodes each one is going to be I
guess it depends on how broken the game
is and how much time I decide to spend
fixing it but yeah it'd be kind of cool
I really like the idea of going back to
old projects opening them up and making
them kind of up-to-date right it's
almost like a remastered kind of version
but not really because I'm not going to
change any assets or anything but it'll
be like more or less the fixed kind of
version which would be pretty cool all
right anyway leave your thoughts below
hit the like button if you enjoyed this
video and if you like the idea and if
you support the idea and I'll see you
guys next time goodbye